ramirez works eight hectares of land and
grows only strawberries
850 tons of strawberries every year to
be precise
the state of michoacan is mexico's main
strawberry growing area but the farming
has taken its toll on the land
water levels in the river here have
dropped the soil is depleted of
nutrients
so ramirez had to change his farming
methods
he bought up more land and installed a
new irrigation system
using technology has made the strawberry
plant more beneficial
in rural areas especially it takes many
liters of water to grow one kilogram of
strawberries
but if you use this type of irrigation
you only need around 30 percent of the
volume
and improving water management is one of
the main goals of
madre chiera a program that supports
hundreds of small-scale strawberry
farmers
it aims to secure a reliable income for
farmers
while not harming the environment it
brings together non-profit organizations
like technoserve and international food
giant dannon
dannon comes regularly to collect large
quantities of strawberries
saving farmers the cost of transport
izitro ramirez's farm now employs 40
people
some of them even returned from the u.s
attracted by the good pay
we're not just creating our own income
now we're even able to employ others
that helps to stop people leaving this
region to go to the cities or other
countries
we want people to gain a foothold here
in their home country
and produce something
he and his son edgar get ready to show
us another new development on the farm
after a consultation with the german
development agency
giz they created strips of green between
the fields and brought in beehives
the giz also explained that biodiversity
results in more productive strawberry
plants
we have our own pollinators and that
means we are sustainable it's clear
where there are bees there is
pollination and that means there's life
the fact that there are bees here shows
that we're using non-aggressive
agrochemicals
which are not detrimental to the
environment we could use herbicides
but we don't because the weeds help
prevent soil erosion
so that when it rains the soil doesn't
wash away
the beehives and the green verges are
just a first step
he also plans to alternate the crops he
plants to allow the soil to recover
alberto rodriguez has already introduced
crop rotation
alternating between onions strawberries
and different varieties of beans
rodriguez only farms two hectares but
the crop rotation has boosted his
harvest considerably
he's also started using insect traps in
the greenhouse
to cut down on the use of pesticides
we had the problem that our plants were
diseased
sometimes we just had to guess what it
could be
we really didn't know what was wrong now
technoserve has provided us with insect
traps
to identify the pests it's helpful
we want to use products that are not
harmful to the environment
the madre tierra program also aims to
improve
standards of hygiene for example proper
toilets have been installed near the
fields
one thing that's very new for alberto
rodriguez is a farming app
it's designed to optimize water
consumption and reduce the amount of
fertilizers and pesticides needed
you register the area say one hectare
and how much product was used
that information is stored it'll be
useful next year
when we create a register of which
products help with which pests
once harvested the strawberries must be
processed quickly while they're still
fresh
the app is helpful to customer danon in
keeping track of the entire production
schedule
and allows the company to ensure their
supplier is sticking to sustainable
practices
dannon's regional sourcing manager
jean-marie garbo
says everyone benefits the farmers the
company and the environment
we think the value chain can be
transformed into a prosperity chain
we benefit from being able to use
various supply lines
which limits the amount of risk for the
company while at the same time
ensuring the farming methods are
sustainable
but the big question is can a
monoculture be genuinely sustainable
rodrigo medellin has his doubts he's an
ecologist at the biggest university in
latin america
if we plant just one species of crop
over large areas of land
we'll feel the effects even pandemics
like the one we're experiencing right
now
can be traced back to monocultures but
there are ways to convert monocultures
so that biodiversity is preserved
in the case of the strawberry
monoculture in michoacan
it seems to be working the madre tierra
project has sought to bring everyone on
board
young and old alike there's now also a
daycare center so that farmers and
workers can drop their kids off when
they go to work
izito ramirez loves to collect his
granddaughter
he hopes that she too will later opt to
stay in michoacan
another incentive to take care of the
environment
for future generations